I have a question for you. Let’s say there’s a
card that, by most considerations, is a great fit
for a deck. It’s pretty powerful, it meshes well
with the way the deck functions mechanically, and
it improves a specific aspect of the deck that was
maybe a bit of a weak spot before. When is putting
that card into that deck the wrong choice? Let’s
take a step back. Commander, as it is played by
most of its playerbase, is a casual format. This
means a lot of things to a lot of people, but the
definition I’ll use here is that a deck is casual
when it is not perfectly optimal in terms of its
ability to perform tasks and win games, and when
this state of being is intentional. If you are a
casual EDH player, by definition there are cards
in your deck that could be switched to different
cards if you wanted to win more games and compete
with more powerful decks. This is intuitively
true to people when it comes to the cards that
most visibly contribute to that winning—the win
conditions. Not every deck includes the most
powerful two card infinite combos in them,
and even among the ones that do, not all of them
run the sort of tutor density that would help
their deck to execute said combos consistently.
Plenty of casual EDH players understand that
they’d prefer to win with Purphoros and a bunch
of goblins rather than Dualcaster plus Twinflame,
and another segment of casual EDH players
understand that they’d prefer to win by
attacking with the aforementioned goblins
rather than dealing damage just by having them
pop into existence. So, this is an area where
players tend to understand their preferences.
However, as you pull back away from what shape
a deck’s win will look like and dive into the
functional meat of decks, things get a little
hazier. You may know approximately how you
enjoy winning, but do you know what forms of
resource building are most enjoyable to you?
Do you know the sort of interaction suite and
style of table engagement that will give you
the most satisfying sort of game? Do you know
how powerful you want each of these components
to be? This is likely an overwhelming sequence of
questions to a lot of people, or even a baffling
sequence of questions to some. This is a card game
where you’re, at least in some abstract sense,
trying to win games, and the natural place a lot
of people end up is finding the most powerful
options out there, or at least playing with the
best options they have access to. And by all
means, don’t let me tell you not to play good
cards—I play lots of good cards! However, I am
also here to tell you that there are some good
cards that, like a Dualcaster-Twinflame combo,
may influence the amount of fun you have with the
game, cards that may not even necessarily have
anything directly to do with winning. What you
find fun about playing your deck may be a lot more
fragile than you think, much more sensitive to the
blunt instrument of an out of place card or two
than you’d expect. If this all sounds like it’s
gearing up for a bunch of aimless good-card hate,
well, why don’t you hear me out for just
a bit. This is all pretty abstract, so a
couple recent examples of this I’ve experienced
are probably in order. Quick side note—I also
released a patron video recently that included
some discussion of the new bracket system,
and I’ll be including a portion of that at
the end of this video. Stick around for that
if you feel like, but with that said, I want to
start off with what may be a familiar example.
In October of last year I discussed my Malfegor
deck, and that one is a vibes deck through and
through. The basic gist is that it is a deck
that pairs discard spells and small creatures
that generate card advantage to try to force
the game into a scrappy, low-resource state
reminiscent of a lot of grindy 60 and 40 card
gameplay, a state where my deck has an edge,
but typically only a slight one. A gritty
gameplan, no doubt, and you’re allowed to hate it,
but I love the sorts of environments this deck can
create, and I likewise enjoy the task of grinding
advantage with a handful of low cost creatures
within those environments. With that in mind,
a useful exercise for understanding what this
deck wants is to consider two powerful cards,
one that ended up in the final deck and one that
did not. Kroxa is a monster of a card—it’s an
effective discard engine that can give opponents
a whiff of pain to come as early as turn 2,
and which also makes for a killer beater that’s
difficult to get rid of. It is very good at doing
everything this deck wants to be good at—making
opponents discard, being resilient, and applying
life total pressure—and that congruence is why it
works in the final deck despite being a crazy good
card in a low-slung budget deck. Waste Not, on
the other hand, is a card that did not end up in
the final deck, and that’s because it is good
at things the deck is not supposed to be good
at. This is a grindy mid-power deck looking to
plunge the game into a low-resource slug fest,
and Waste Not handing me easy resources boosts
me out of that state, changing the whole dynamic
of the deck. The fun part of the deck for me is
when I’m clawing for advantage in a scrappy game,
and if a two mana enchantment just hands
me a bunch of advantage, it shortcuts that,
basically just turning my deck into a
generic oppressive stax deck in the process.
This was the example of a good card being a
bad idea that got me thinking harder about
the concept, but there’s a similar and even more
striking recent example that ended up inspiring
this video. In mid-January I was looking at
spoilers for Aetherdrift seeing if there was
anything new for my Sharuum Astral Slide deck,
and I saw the card Monument to Endurance. On the
surface, this thing is a slam dunk in a cycling
deck—cycled cards get effortlessly transfigured
into resources at a rate of one per turn, allowing
for an easy card advantage engine that can pivot
into a win condition, and which can even provide
treasures where needed. Can you believe that all
of that could come from a single magic card?
It’s almost too good to be true! Actually,
not almost—it is too good to be true in
this case. I discussed in my video about
this deck that at its heart this is a control
deck that cares about navigating a sequence
of tricky choices about where to divert the
deck’s resources. Do I tutor for a high-cost
artifact that gives me card advantage,
or one that slows down my opponents? Do
I flicker an ETB creature that shuts down
a problematic spell or ability, or one that
makes my board larger? Do I use Sharuum’s
recur ability to bring back a key blocker,
or a card that pushes my own advantage? These
are the sorts of choices that make this deck a
highly fun and engaging experience for me when I’m
looking to sit down and think hard during a game.
The issue with Monument to Endurance,
then, is that it shortcuts around
this whole thing. Its ability doesn’t
compete with anything else in the deck,
and the correct first choice per turn
will almost always be card draw. Suddenly,
easily the most effective draw engine in my deck
isn’t a multi-card flicker-based engine that I
need to piece together and then operate
with lots of decisions along the way—no,
this is a do-thing-get-cards engine, where
taking a game action, cycling in this case,
is immediately and directly rewarded with
drawing cards. This simplification of value
generation decisions has a cascading effect
of simplifying my tutoring decisions—it will
almost always be correct to hunt up a one-piece
engine like this, and so my tutoring decisions
will reflect that—I’ll wizardcycle for a
Trophy Mage to grab my Monument to Endurance,
because anything else would be an irresponsible
choice. Suddenly, the task of gaining advantage
has one simple route of administration—find the
card that makes my cycling cards do more cycling,
play it, and then the advantage makes itself.
There are two other cards I exclude for similar
reasons—the draw doublers Alhammarett’s Archive
and Teferi’s Ageless Insight are undoubtedly
strong in a cycling deck, but they’re strong by
shortcutting the value generating part of the
deck, allowing me to get ahead simply by cycling
rather than by making use of Astral Slide and ETB
creatures. These generic do-thing-get-cards
synergies would suck the identity and a lot
of the interesting decisions out of the deck,
thereby removing a lot of what makes it fun to me.
Now, you might assume based on what I just said
that I hate all draw that’s too generic or simple
or powerful, or even that I dislike the sort of
do-things-get-cards draw I mentioned earlier.
That’s not the case, though—I dislike it in the
case of my Sharuum deck specifically because it
shortcuts past what I find fun about the deck,
simplifying the rich tapestry of decisions that
the deck presents me with and rendering the
more interesting forms of value pointlessly
weak by comparison. If you find the process
of building advantage a particularly fun one,
you’ll want to be careful with the cards you add,
but this won’t be the case for all decks. I run
a bunch of these sorts of simple, strong value
engines I mentioned earlier in my Radha deck,
Beast Whisperer and Garruk’s Packleader and such
like, and those feel great there. If anything
I wish my draw was even more straightforward
sometimes—many people who’ve seen me playing the
deck have witnessed me exasperatedly resolving
my fifth Radagast trigger in a turn, playing
as quickly as possible in an effort to keep my
turn length under five minutes despite casting
dozens of mana worth of spells. This is because
exactly how I build advantage isn’t something I
care about. There are two main things I find fun
about playing this deck—having a ton of mana,
which enables me to have these intense and complex
turns with intricate ordering, and figuring out
how to beat down my opponents with a big ol’ ol
pile of budget bombs. I do run draw in the deck,
but I just treat it as a means to an end, with
that end being allowing me to spend my ample mana
and not end up hellbent too much of the time.
In the case of this deck, what would shortcut
the fun would be running more powerful bombs and
finishers that allow me to convert mana advantage
into defeated opponents more efficiently. I like
playing the role of a final boss with this deck,
pumping my volume of gameplay up to seismic
proportions before lumbering in the direction
of victory with my large creatures.
I do have ways to close out games,
but they’re not super fast or sudden unless I’m
at 20 or more mana, and this gives opponents
a fighting chance to claw their way back into
the game and best me in some games. These big,
dynamic back-and-forths are some of my favorite
games with the deck, and if I spent a bunch of
effort tuning my deck to win faster I wouldn’t
get these sorts of games nearly as often.
For a similar example, let’s talk about my friend
Hans’ Lilah, Undefeated Slickshot deck, named
Izzet Bizzet. This is a control-oriented deck
that plays as many Prophetic Bolts as possible,
with prophetic bolt as a category referring to
an Izzet card that can both deal damage and draw
one or more cards. I asked Hans what he finds
fun about the deck, and he responded simply “I
like to 2 for 1 people twice.” Prophetic Bolt
in 1v1 formats is the archetypal mana-expensive
2 for 1 card—you pay 5 mana to hopefully
remove a creature with 4 or less toughness,
as well as finding a card in the top 4 cards of
your library, thereby generating two cards worth
of value with your one Magic: the Gathering card.
This type of card feels less impactful in EDH,
what with its ample value engines and two
additional opponents and such like, but allowing
each of these spells to be used an additional
time suddenly makes for a much more tempting
proposition. The resulting deck looks to build
value while keeping opponents in check, gradually
adding additional mana in the form of mana rocks
as well as occasional amplifier permanents before
trying to overwhelm opponents with value and
gradually burn them down. It was one of these
amplifier permanents that ended up being a problem
for shortcutting the fun—Thousand Year Storm.
See, this deck typically keeps around a
handful of plotted Izzet instants that
were weaved into an endstep, holding them
in exile until they’re ready to be cast for
free on a main phase later. This means
that with a minimal amount of planning,
a Thousand Year Storm turn can easily reach
five or more cast spells, which could mean the
final couple spells of a turn being copied several
times. This won’t always be an immediate game win,
but it effectively nullifies value as a
concept in the deck—the deck is likely
adding ten or more cards to its hand each
turn that Thousand Year Storm is in play,
and possibly digging dozens of cards deep into its
library. Worse, TYS negates the concept of mana as
well—when a five or six cost card can be copied
half a dozen times, the progression of adding
on mana rocks and amplifiers becomes entirely
pointless. Anything before the TYS barely matters,
and whether or not it results in an imminent game
win more or less comes down to a removal check
for opponents unless the deck was far behind when
the storm came into play. So, Thousand Year Storm
does shortcut the fun in the case of this deck
by pushing the deck beyond what it’s supposed to
care about-getting 2-for-1s. However, this isn’t
to say that all powerful amplifier permanents
are off the table. The new Niv-Mizzet printed
in foundations feels shockingly okay here—it
does end up somewhat negating the resource of
cards, but mana is still a big limiting factor
for the deck. Not needing to worry nearly as much
about value does change the nature of the deck,
but the deck still feels like a version of itself,
and the things that are fun about it remain fun
even if the play pattern becomes a bit different.
The same goes for the card that ended up replacing
Thousand Year Storm—Swarm Intelligence certainly
amplifies the deck’s gameplay substantially,
but it’s still in the realm of being
reasonable. The difference between a
2x amplification and a 3-4x amplification ends
up being a lot more tangible than you’d expect.
All four of these cases provide examples of ways
to avoid shortcutting the fun, ways to experience
the enjoyable parts of decks for a greater
percentage of the time you play them through
simple card choice decisions. These probably seem
simple when I present them like this, but these
are play patterns that took months or longer to
figure out, and decisions that often took trial
and error to come to a firm conclusion about. In
addition, these sorts of decisions might take a
real change of deckbuilding framework for players.
So, what’s a good place to start? For one, figure
out what you find fun in decks. Pay attention
to how you’re feeling during games—when are
you having the most fun? For a lot of people, it
might be the middle-later portions of games, where
things are up and running but before the deck is
actively closing things out or losing. For those
people, ask yourself—are there cards that might be
winning your games prematurely, before your deck
has spent the expected length of time building
up to them and before you’ve spent as much time
as you’d like savoring that part of the game? I
find that avoiding a lot of the higher-powered
wincons is good for this—I often run tools that
allow me to quickly eliminate a single player if
I commit hard enough, but higher-level tools that
will rapidly guarantee an all-out victory should
be treated with care if you’re not playing a
deck that necessarily wants to win as fast as
possible. This principle goes for accomplishing
tasks as well—if there are a specific set of
interactions that make a deck fun and meaningful
to you, the worst possible thing you can do is
add a different set of cards that does the same
thing better, and in a less interesting way.
If you have a deck that focuses on dungeons
and the initiative, adding in a Rhystic Study
and a Trouble in Pairs will probably improve the
deck, but suddenly you might find these unrelated
cards outshining the set of value engines you
built your whole deck around. Maybe that’s fine
if you’re looking for raw power, but if that
was my deck I’d find that a bit of a bummer.
For other players, the win might be the highlight
of the game. If you find wins at any cost
enjoyable, you should probably go out and find
your local cEDH community, but for everybody else,
you should ask yourself: what makes wins feel
satisfying? I know I enjoy winning games when
it feels earned, when it feels like I’ve outplayed
my opponents and overcome challenges. This can be
tackled from a lot of different differection,
but there are cases where avoiding cards that
accomplish tasks too efficiently can help with
this. Put bluntly, it’s really not very hard to
make an EDH deck that wins games if you’re willing
to throw the best cards into a deck and learn how
to play them in the right order. I don’t tell you
to exclude good cards because I have some sort of
vendetta against them, I tell you that doing that
might be worth considering because running some
of the less flashy tools this game has to offer
makes the game more enjoyable, more interesting,
more textured for me, and it also makes wins
more satisfying. Completing the same task with
much more niche hardware is a lot of fun, and can
engage a lot of deckbuilding and gameplay muscles
that just aren’t fully engaged if you’re playing
with top of the line materials. This can even go
for decks that flirt with a more combo-oriented
playstyle. I released a video about a $25 eggs
deck in mid-last year, and the main thrust of
that video was that not having access to a key
mana engine, Krark Clan Ironworks, forced the
deck to traverse its explosive storm gameplan
in much more intentional and dynamic ways than
would be required if it did have access to KCI.
Playing with weaker connecting material or
payoffs can really bring out some more fun
and textured elements from explosive decks which
might otherwise effortlessly combo off and win.
I also want to acknowledge that putting worse
cards in a deck is hard. It goes against the
deckbuilding instincts of a lot of people, and
the idea that it might be the correct choice
to produce the most fun experience might be kind
of alarming if it’s not a thought you’ve tangled
with before. Optimization is a big piece
of deckbuilding in a card game like Magic:
the Gathering, and I’d be a liar if I pretended
that optimization wasn’t a big piece of what
informs the way I play the game. Depending on
who you ask, I’d probably be categorized as
a Spike or a Melvin, and the idea of building
a maximally effective machine for purposes of
crushing my opponents is one that will never
stop being appealing to me. But casual EDH
as a format is just that—it’s a casual, social
format. Winning can never be the only concern,
and to enjoy this format long-term you need to
find things that are meaningful to you outside of
crushing your opponents. The solution isn’t even
necessarily to abandon the optimization instinct,
but rather to optimize for something that isn’t
raw power level. You can think of it as optimizing
for fun, but it’s going to be easier to tackle
if you identify some more specific goal. For me,
that’s building a deck that embodies a specific
feeling through its design, a specific vibe,
but for you that might be something different.
Building a deck that best utilizes Dollhouse of
Horrors. Building the most effective turtle
deck. Building the most turtle-y deck that’s
still effective. Whatever it is, identify it
and chase it. Your efforts will be rewarded.
Thanks for watching, and thanks
to Archidekt for supporting the
channel. Archidekt is my deckbuilding
site of choice due to its satisfying
visual layout and well-designed category
system. A link to my decks is in the
description. Thank you to my patrons as
well for making what I do here possible,
and here’s a preview of a patron-only video
I released that discussed the bracket system.